how do you feel about Nashville these
days I'm pretty sick of it
honestly a lot of my friends are moving
because and don't take it personally La
no offense but I'm just like this ain't
my place it's not ain't for everybody
all love but Nashville's becoming very
La a lot of La people are moving to
Nashville and it's just the reason we
moved there I'm from Kentucky but a lot
of my family is actually from Nashville
and growing up as a kid when go visit
Nashville didn't feel any different than
Kentuck small town Kentucky it was a
small town it's now it'sing filled with
bachelorette parties and they got every
country star has a bar don't get me
wrong I love a bar for the money but I
don't they've just ruined Broadway it's
the whole things of show there's
traffic everywhere you can't get
anywhere it's like I just want to chill